- Après ce contact en apparence
banal, un coup d'épaule
à la poitrine, Damar Haml
se relève, puis s'effondre.
- And now another Bill's player
is down...
- Ça fait plus de 25 ans que
je suis dans le monde du foot
puis j'ai jamais été témoin
de quelque chose comme ça.
- L'ancien joueur des Alouettes
Matthieu Proulx faisait
l'analyse du match sur
les ondes de RDS.
MATTHIEU PROULX, analyste de
football à RDS
- Il s'est levé puis il est
tombé comme il est tombé, comme
un boxeur était passé le K.-O.
Déjà, à ce moment-là, quelques
secondes après, on se disait
que c'était pas normal.
- Les soigneurs se précipitent
pour pratiquer des manoeuvres de
imimimation sur le jeune homme
de 24 ans. Son pouls est rétabli
avec un défibrillateur.
C'est le choc et la stupeur
sur le terrain.AlAlAlors que set
pour lui, le maraudeur des Bills
de Buffalo est transporté
à l'hôpital.
Le match est suspendu.
(sirènes)
On pense que Damar Hamlin
aurait été victime
d'une commotion cardiaque,
un événement extrêmement rare.
Le choc qu'il a reçutttt
entraîné un arrêt du coeur.
Dr CHRISTOPHER LABOS,
cardiologue
- C'est pas commun du tout'o'o',
mais ça arrive quand on a
un coup précisément à la cage
thoracique, directement
au-dessus du coeur.
Ça doit arriver quand le coeur
est en train de se repolariser,
dans les quelques millisecondes
où ça se passe.
Dr FRANÇOIS SIMARD, cardiologue,
Institut de cardiologie de Mtl
- Et s'il arrive un choc
important exactement
à ce moment-là, bien là,
le coeur développe une arythmie
complètement désorganisée,
qu'on appelle de la fibrillation
ventriculaire, et qui en fai
c'est synonyme en fait
d'une mort subite.
- Mais grâce à l'intervention
rapide des secours, le joueur
des Bills pourrait s'en remettre
sans trop de séquelles.
- Le plus rapidement qu'on peut
utiliser un défibrillateur
pour choquer le coeur, pour
le remettre en rythme normal,
c'est ça qui va prédire si
quelqu'un a une récupération
totale ou non.
fofofofofort possible qu'il aura
une récupération totale. Il est
jeune, il n'a pas de problèmes
médicaux, à ce qu'on sache.
- "C'est un battant, il s'en
sortira", dit un de ses amis.
- We're family...
- Les partisans sont derrière
lui, comme en témoignent
ces images.
Autre preuve de solidarité :
les dons affluent à la fondation
mid d d d d d par Damar Hamlin
pour distribuer des jouets
aux enfants pauvres.
Plus de 4 millions de dollarson.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.